le froid toujours avec des températures
ressenties jusqu'à -13 degrés hier les
mesures d' aide aux sans abri se
renforce et les maraudes se sont
multipliés à celle du soir et de la nuit
la croix-rouge d'indre et loire a ajouté
des marottes de jours depuis jeudi et
jusqu'à dimanche
au delà du réconfort l'urgence est de
guider les sans abri vers l'une des 750
places d'hébergement disponibles sur le
département
aurélie renault cristal et anne on
repérer quelqu'un rue des halles
le contact se fait grâce à un chocolat
le jeune homme a 22 ans il serait
hébergée par une connaissance
mais il passe ses journées dans la rue
la température ressentie est de -10
degrés durant ces quatre jours de grand
froid les maraudes habituellement en
place le soir vont également avoir lieu
en journée sur demande de la préfecture
on vient de croiser quelqu'un en fait
qu'il y avait juste une chemise et un
blouson d'été sur le dos
là on a vu des hommes on a vu des femmes
on n'a pas vu d'enfants mais ça ça peut
arriver beaucoup quand même en forte
proportion sont quand même des hommes
durant la maraude un appel d'urgence
c'est le 115
une femme et ses trois enfants ont
besoin dead ils dorment dans leur
voiture depuis deux semaines la mère de
famille et l'un de ses fils de 2 ans
arrive près du camion ils viennent de
bulgarie une habitante de tours-nord
elle aussi bulgare se charge de la
traduction
elle leur a offert à manger et leur a
prêté sa salle de bain durant quelques
jours mais aujourd'hui elle s'inquiète
pour eux les nuits sont glaciales
hormis les aventuriers parking et les
mariés et partent il est sympa se plaît
donnez les personnes nées avant cet
après midi là les bénévoles trouve une
place dans un centre pour toute la
famille ils seront logés jusqu'au 30
mars
une assistante sociale leur sera
également proposée s'il trouve le
logement ce soir s'ils osent y aller et
s'y trouvait le joint après ça va se
mettre en route en faite le
le système voilà dead va pouvoir y
seront connus ils seront identifiés y
aura éventuellement à un numéro de
téléphone donc le réseau dette qui en
place va pouvoir fonctionner mais il
faut qu'ils fassent ce pas là en fait
selon les associations environ 80
personnes seraient sans abri aujourd'hui
à tours